guy paragliding on a lake and Landing
too low and a tree fully up as anus had
to re what's it called
structure whole butthole and everything
around it cuz it was like you can get
like paragliding like you have the thing
but you're basically like asking for it
but uh like CU you're supposed to like
pull your legs up you're basically like
receiving a treat great receiving kind
like a pine uh I think no no I think
it's like a mangrove type thing like
like the angle was there too to be like
oh God like a big br and again tree I
guess we should more say like
potentially like bushy man grve but like
strong strong arm so he got stuck on it
or did he break the tree off while
Landing up his butt sers you would get I
didn't actually have followup questions
for my dad that's the only thing I cuz
this was he told us this a long time ago
maybe what if what if he just didn't
want to take us paragliding that sounds
like